i think about if i ran a news network
i'd probably just make my number one
story uh kanye west pete davidson and
kim kardashian which used to be the e
network yeah i mean but whatever right
that's exactly right i know pete robot
like he's just a kid trying to live his
life i've had one of my favorite people
yeah he's just a [ __ ] smart funny uh
kid trying to live his life and and he's
just caught up in you know and he's
doing i think he's doing uh
as best you can in that situation when
you're dealing with with
something that's so explosive and
and loaded with all kinds of other uh
things and uh
i just love that kid how do you know him
from the comedy clubs is that how you
met him i think because i'm incredibly
hip and with it yes i think that kids
yeah i think i think you know a lot of
times i walk down the street and people
will say who's that ernest borgnine
looking [ __ ]
i'd like to
i'd like to hang out with that guy no he
and i know each other from comedy from
from going on the road uh
dave dave and i were doing gigs in
boston and houston and pete came out and
performed and him and mullany worked
near where i live in jersey so i would
go and buy pizza from a place and we'd
just go hang out and we just became we
became friends uh from that and i you
know i always have like a you know a
very paternal instinct on on those guys
you know you always feel like because
you you just i've seen too many of my
friends
get in trouble
and some of them die
and and you don't
you know
do young guys it's a [ __ ] up business
these younger guys when they see you at
these comedy clubs uh do they ask your
advice do they seek you out sometimes
but but not explicitly like that i think
it's more you know how this is like that
it's that back table at the at the club
and everybody's doing their sets and
it's it's the the fun of why we got into
it
is to hang out with
to not have a real job to dress like
[ __ ] to go out at night and and drink
and eat lousy food and hang out with
other hopefully very funny people uh i
do think at times there's there's a
stereotype about the comedy world as
being
sort of not
supportive or not and it's and it is
like look it's it's a business it's
cutthroat to some extent but there's a
real camaraderie